katar wir brauchen gas und wir suchen
alternativen zu russland meine frage ist
sehr ambivalent ich weiß realpolitik ist
nicht immer schön realpolitik ist nicht
immer schwarz und weiß aber muss das rad
auch sein dass es eigentlich gehabt
katar ist der exportweltmeister von
islamismus nicht diejenigen die
terroranschläge verüben wollen sondern
diejenigen die mit unterwanderung
strategien mit viel geld versuchen
unsere demokratie auf dauer zu schwächen
wir haben sie in deutschland wir haben
wie in frankreich wir haben sie in
london und vielen anderen ländern auch
das thema antisemitismus durch al jazira
aus katar ist ein thema die in der welt
geht dürfen natürlich auch nicht
vergessen dass 15.000 arbeiter bei der
vorbereitung und er auf und der bau von
stadien für die weltmeisterschaft dieses
jahr schon gestorben sind ich frage mich
warum ein minister aus deutschland sich
verneigen muss welche interkultureller
trainer hat ihn dazu beraten das sind
bilder die natürlich auch uns länger
beschäftigen sollen und meine grundfrage
mussten wir eine faschistische ideologie
mit einer andere faschistische ideologie
tauschen und du bist hier alternativen
gibt
ich glaube wie der der blick nach katar
ist ist enorm wichtig sie haben gerade
angesprochen und es wird jetzt in den in
den kommenden monaten zu sein dass wir
uns intensiv mit diesem land
beschäftigen werden weil eben das wird
jetzt in der aktuellen diskussion um die
gas ankäufe ein stückweit vergessen bald
findet dort die fußball
weltmeisterschaft statt es wird die
menschenrechtslage in den in den fokus
noch weiter geraten und die ist alles
andere als gut und am ende glaube ich
jetzt mal aber einer situation wo man
sagen muss ok welche alternativen gibt
es da draußen noch also müssen wir am
ende nicht in diesen sauren apfel beißen
und sagen wir haben keine andere
möglichkeit als mit katar die also ich
glaube dass genervte die ich glaube
schon dass alternativen da gibt und wenn
es alternativen los ist dann will ich
auch mit denen ober menschenrechte
sprechen ich will mit denen auch über
strategien dass ihre islamismus geld
nicht europa kommt dass sie hier nicht
irgendwelche problematische moschee
vereine unterstützen die nicht jetzt auf
die religion ausübung hinaus sind
sondern auf ganz viele
undemokratischer inhalte die wir hier
verbreiten wollen all diese gespräche
fanden nicht statt sondern man findet
sich in eine notlage sucht alternativen
und blendet komplett aus dass wir hier
mit einer islamismus land zu tun muss
man sagen ich geh weg hat ein video
gemacht das war auch glaube ich drei
minuten lang und in dem video hat er
darauf hingewiesen dass er den emir auf
menschenrechte angesprochen hat dass er
darüber geredet hat er hat darauf
hingewiesen dass sie haben jetzt darüber
muss man eigentlich auch nicht wenig
kann es auch sehr witzig von herbeck
aber darauf hingewiesen dass jetzt ein
mindestlohn haben in katar der
mindestlohn beträgt 300 euro der wird
auch laut auch er habe im video auch
nicht ganz durchgehalten aber herr
habeck hat in diesem video schon und
auch wenn ich ich teile total deine
meinung aber ein harter weg angesehen in
diesem video das ihm unwohl war mit
katar und er hat auf die menschenrechte
hingewiesen nur ich gebe ihnen komplett
recht oder dir kommt nicht recht wie
kann es denn sein also ich muss sagen
und damit werde ich es nicht beliebt
machen ganz ehrlich alles machen wir wir
verbeugen uns vor dem ihr aber
atomenergie darüber möchte keiner mehr
reden ich bin dafür dass man jetzt alle
lösungen wie das ist eine andere
geschichte mit der atomenergie da reden
wir darüber dass das über 100.000 jahre
bewacht werden muss und so künftige
dessen an das thema
bleiben ich glaube tatsächlich dass wenn
deutsches regierungsmitglied sowas macht
und das tun die natürlich nicht gerne es
geht um kurzfristige überbrückung weil
wir möglichen raus wollen aus dem
energieabhängigkeit bewusst sein dass er
sehr wohl über menschenrechte dann rede
und das auch getan hat andererseits
lange weil andererseits muss ich sagen
haben sie natürlich an einem punkt recht
ich habe null sympathie warum wir zum
beispiel solche sportveranstaltungen da
machen da sollten wir auch mal über die
strukturen bei der fifa und beim
olympischen komitee mit wem die sich so
verbrüdern da wünsche ich mir auch ein
bisschen mehr übersichtlichkeit
gegenüber den amateuren das ist nämlich
nicht der fall das muss man klipp und
klar sagen da herrscht ein umgang muss
ich sagen meine mode sport funktionieren
also das ist teilweise hat das
sizilianische ausmaße was man da
besichtigen keine blatter und co was wir
da gesehen das ist nicht gut da
hinzugehen die fußballweltmeisterschaft
zu machen handeln damit andererseits
muss man eben auch sagen wenn man mal
guckt egon bahr hat mal gesagt wenn wir
nur noch mit denen reden die unsere
werte teilen sind wir mit norwegen nicht
allein ist ein bisschen wenig sie haben
es natürlich mit diktaturen über als ist
in china ist eine türkei ist kein
demokratisches land wir haben teilweise
in der europäischen union
schwierigkeiten mit rechtsstaatlichkeit
in ungarn und polen und also insofern
ist es auch ein problem wir stellen halt
jetzt fest dass wir halt ein land ohne
rohstoffe also jedenfalls ohne die das
können wir nicht wenige das können wir
nicht schnell ändern es stellen wir
jetzt fest aber wir haben ja einen
tollen rohstoff krebs und meine
anforderung an die politik und das ist
die elle mit der ich messe ist setzen
wir den ausreichend ein und deshalb
hilft es jetzt nichts zu sagen ich habe
mit dem man auch über menschenrechte
gerät ist ja lächerlich sondern auch zu
hören man so würde ich sagen die
ehrlichkeit besteht darin heute zu sagen
wir werden noch fünf jahre geschäfte mit
schuften machen müssen das ist so das
sind schufte die haben alle stehen für
andere wertesysteme aber das ist jetzt
so das müssen wir machen weil es kein
oder nur wenig gute alternative wir
versprechen euch aber diese fünf jahre
mit unserem krebs zu benutzen wie wir
aus diesen abhängigkeiten rauskommen und
wenn ich die politik der ampel richtig
verfolge ist das ja die zielsetzung sie
wird jetzt nur nicht bullish und mit
großer überzeugung vor allem im ersten
teil wir müssen halt geschäfte mit
schriften machen das wird jeder
verstehen an jedem stammtisch wird es
verstanden weil jeder in seinem
privatleben auch weiß du kannst nicht
dein ganzes leben lang nur mit menschen
geschäfte betreiben die alle deine werte
teilen jeder muss irgendwann eurem
geschäftsleben einen tod sterben aber
wenn er gestorben ist da passt die
metapher nicht ganz dann geht es ja
sozusagen weiter und ich habe mich dann
befreit und das wird die entscheidende
frage sein was geschieht jetzt
eigentlich nach dem handschlag mit dem
scheich um aus dieser abhängigkeit
herauszukommen weil ihr eingangs
statement man macht mit dem ein diktator
am besten nichts mehr um es dann mit
einem anderen islamisten menschen zu
machen ist ja nicht überzeugt und was
ganz
entscheidender punkt auch noch ist was
man vielleicht hier so ein stück weit
vergess ich halt 2014 15 und 16 die
ersten male in katar und habe über die
tatsächlich sehr katastrophale
menschenrechtslage da geschrieben und
auch über dieses erlöse vergabe der der
fifa also der der fußball
weltmeisterschaft durch die fifa und was
mir jetzt über die letzten jahre hatte
zuletzt auch einen termin mit einigen
katarischen funktionieren aufgefallen
ist die beobachten schon sehr genau wie
wir hier in deutschland diskutieren wie
wir über sie reden also es ist ihnen
sehr wichtig dass das image dass das
image in deutschland in europa und ich
glaube schon die die vorwürfe die sie
genannt haben sind mit sicherheit
richtig aber das ist gerade auch im
blick auf die menschenrechtslage sehr
wohl verbesserungen auch gibt es darf
man nicht ignorieren durch diesen
internationalen druck der jetzt seit 8
das bedeutet dass homosexuelle für
zunächst drei jahre in unserer gestern
ist jetzt darüber reden herr das sind
die fragen die werte journalisten als
politiker erst recht nach hinten gegen
hersteller schnell der eine punkt ich
glaube wie
ich habe auch gesagt es ist realpolitik
ich kann es auch nachvollziehen aber wir
haben hier nicht nur noch ein diktatur
zu tun es ist auch kein wunder dass in
den letzten jahren auch massive
anspricht spannungen zwischen katar und
ihre nachbarländern weil sie massiv eine
islamismus export betreibt und ich hätte
mir gewünscht dass man auch jetzt
darüber nachdenkt wie kann deutschland
sich sicher dass es auch beim islamismus
beim geld das sie an katar bezahlt nicht
wieder in islamismus geld in deutschland
darüber finde ich muss man das ist nicht
sehr populär aber auch man muss ja eins
wissen ich kann menschenrechte
einfordern mit megaphon kann
demonstrationen machen kann überlegen
was ist davon wirksam in diktaturen ich
weiß aber sehr wohl dass manchmal hinter
verschlossenen türen dinge erreicht
werden gerade zugunsten von menschen die
vom fonds über die keiner redet aber von
dem wir wissen das ist der fall ist und
dass es auch ehrenhaften wobei sie
natürlich recht haben so was muss ja
insgesamt über 100 medienvertreter
machen und die schleusen jetzt ein paar
mehr leute ein die hier islamistisches
land untereinander ist das sehr schlecht
angelegtes geld da muss man natürlich
reden ich bin nur reden ich muss ich
muss einmal noch auf unseren clubs
zurückkommen also natürlich wäre es
besser gewesen katar die fußball
weltmeisterschaft nicht aber jetzt haben
sie sich gar nicht und vielleicht sind
wir sind gar nicht auseinander glaube
ich will einen punkt loswerden
jetzt ist es ist die
fußball-weltmeisterschaft dort und dann
bin ich dann auch dafür da verträge
eingehalten werden und die dort
stattfindet aber lasst es doch jetzt
unseren krebs nutzen um genau diesen weg
den sie beschrieben haben jetzt
fortzusetzen
also in katar gebe jetzt eine riesige
bühne auf für alle die auf ihr
wertesystem aufmerksam machen wollen und
damit der ganzen welt sagen dass werde
das system des veranstalter landes kommt
dann doch nicht mit oder ist anders oder
ist verwerflich ich erwarte dass es
hat eine art demonstration dort geben
wird es kann der bundeskanzler kann zu
einem spiel der deutschen
nationalmannschaft fahren und kann sich
entsprechend menschenrechtler mitnehmen
die können dann dort auch was hochhalten
das wird die fifa nicht übertragen wenn
es nicht schnell genug aber das kann man
ja jetzt alles machen also lasst uns die
qatar bühne jetzt nutzen um für unser
wertesystem werbung zu machen und wenn
dann jemand ich werde jetzt einmal nur
ein bisschen zynisch aber ich hoffe sie
sehen es mir nach wenn dann jemand der
vorher zehn jahre ins gefängnis musste
nur noch eins des gefängnis muss ist es
immer noch schlecht und verwerflich aber
schon besser geworden